wayfarer airlines flight 515 was an  important part of the breaking bad  mythology a symbol of the horrible  consequences of walter white's actions  his decision to let jesse's girlfriend  jane die leads to her father an air  traffic controller inadvertently causing  a mid-air collision the crash was subtly  teased with black and white prologues  flashing forward to the disaster all  through the second season of breaking  bad saul goodman milked the wayfarer  disaster for all it was worth wearing a  memorial ribbon on his lapel for the  remainder of breaking bad in the better  call saul series finale he's extradited  back to new mexico from omaha to plead  guilty to his many crimes flying with a  u.s marshal and you can tell from the  seats it's a wayfarer flight  later he enters the courtroom in a shiny  suit complete with his memorial ribbon  still pinned to the lapel